[Music]  it's a Hills baby boom Heidi and Spencer  are expecting are you guys thinking  about it now are you just right where we  started I was thinking Oh wouldn't that  be so cute if there is a kid it's box  big yeah but you guys are wanting to do  expand the family beyond the fur babies  yes that was the couple last spring when  et visited them at home to talk the  tenth anniversary of the MTV hit the  main issue we're dealing with is the  child's name once we have a name Locke  you know these these people have some  very wild names these days and I want to  have a more wild name than them  now Spidey's dream has come true Us  Weekly broke the pregnancy news at  Wednesday morning that means all four  original Hill's girls will be moms by  the end of 2017  Lauren Conrad and Whitney port are also  pregnant and Audrina Patridge welcome to  daughter Kira last summer your life just  changes your priorities change and  everything